[Music]
et catching up with Zac Efron who's now
the face of Hugo urban journey by Hugo
Boss what do you want to do today not
only did eat dish about the fragrance
line these are three amazing sense that
I have kind of ibed with he also opened
up about portraying notorious serial
killer Ted Bundy in the movie extremely
wicked shockingly evil and vile Affleck
he just wrapped filming I saw that
transformation video that you posted and
man what is it like to get into such a
serious and dark place it's very
interesting I think the movie itself is
it's deep it's really deep it doesn't
really glorify Ted Bundy he wasn't a
person to be glorified it simply tells
the story of how the world was able to
be charmed over by this guy who was
notoriously evil it was fun to to go and
an experiment in that realm of reality
that's got to be so crazy to be on set
16 hours a day and you go back to your
hotel at a long day of shooting it's got
to be a little bit of a are you like to
get your mind right yeah a little bit a
little bit you know III went and had
some friends like sage me you know like
do a little spiritual cleansing thank
you you know I didn't go full method and
I didn't have to like do any weird stuff
to anybody to you into character he also
dished on his wild do for the upcoming
film the beach bum and then some wild
wig situation for beach bum
uh now that wasn't a wig that was not
real hair wait what yeah no no I was
legit that was that was all me it was
crazy and then I got to meet up with
Matthew McConaughey it was one of the
most fun sets of Eben's we go way back
like paperboy
like you much either I looked at that
guy my entire life basically but really
we connected on paper boy and to revisit
and set hangout what it was there's like
a dream sequence in my brain Zack of
like you and Matthew McConaughey like
running on the beach we weren't we
weren't on the beach but we did do some
like good runs he can run like an animal
no honestly he's insane I was I'm in
pretty good shape and he just he just
dusted me Matthews he's he's an animal